heute morgen muss ich noch nicht dass
ich für diese Erdbeeren bis nach Holland
fahre
ich wurde heute entführt von Hamza er
hat gesagt steig einfach ein wir fahren
los wir sind dann angekommen beim
leckersten Erdbeerstand der Welt und
hier ist einfach der Besitzer zum
Nachdenken ist rausgefunden er war so
sympathisch und meinte eigentlich müssen
wir reservieren aber wir haben es noch
geschafft die Wartezeit ging echt
ziemlich schnell rum es waren so viele
Autos dann einige auch zu Fuß aber es
ging super schnell voran unterwegs gab's
dann immer wieder Schilder die uns
gesagt haben wie lange es noch dauert
und angekommen gab es dann ganz viele
Speisekarte natürlich hatte jedes Jahr
auf der Speisekarte etwas mit Erdbeeren
zu tun wir haben uns einfach alles in
den Notizen gespeichert und die Liste
dann der Kassiererin gegeben und was wir
probiert haben das zeige ich euch dann
im nächsten Video